ces poissons bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur ard france alors
cette décision du conseil d'état fait
suite à une saisine en référé pas
plusieurs associations et requérant
individuel individuel donc fait partie
c'est une victoire pour vous bien sûr
c'est une victoire parce que nous avions
voulu contester avec le parti chrétien
démocrate auquel je me suis joint à
titre personnel ce que nous considérions
comme une atteinte aux libertés
fondamentales de tous les français
qu'ils soient croyants ou pas puisque
notre constitution aux textes
fondamentaux garantissent à toute
personne vivant en france le droit plein
et entier d'exercer de pratiquer le
culte qui le souhaitent ou de ne pas en
pratique et et dans la liberté de culte
il y a la possibilité et le droit de se
réunir pour célébrer les offices
religieux ce qui a été contesté hier par
conseil d'état c'est la disproportion
que représente une interdiction générale
et absolue de se réunir pour célébrer
des offices dans une période de
déconfinement grosso modo le conseil
d'état nous a rejoint en considérant que
quand on a le droit d'aller faire ses
courses chez le coiffeur dans une
bibliothèque dans un musée en respectant
des conditions sanitaires
il ya aucune raison d'empêcher les
croyantes se réunir les autres
d'ailleurs pour célébrer les offices
religieux c'est donc une victoire
effectivement pour les libertés
fondamentales donc pour tous les
français là comment voilà vous allez
vous organiser concrètement quelles
mesures vont pouvoir être appliquée à
l'intérieur des églises
voilà pour pour respecter la
dispensation social est fait les mesures
barrières alors moi je n'étais pas
m'organiser particulièrement parce que
jeune fille dans cette affaire pas du
tout porte parole des croyants ni ni les
cultes
nous avons agi comme un parti politique
donc pour le compte de tous les français
et encore une fois sur des principes de
libertés fondamentales et de droit il
appartient maintenant aux responsables
les cultes de parler avec les
gouvernements pour qu'ils définissent
ensemble la manière concrète dont les
offices vont pouvoir se dérouler en
donnant droit au rêve de sanitaires qui
doivent être respectées dans les lieux
de culte comme ailleurs le conseil des
évêques de france a envoyé visiblement
il ya trois semaines maintenant au
gouvernement un document décrivant par
le menu la manière dont on pouvait
s'organiser dans les églises
pour célébrer les officiers respecter
les conditions sanitaires il appartient
maintenant à la communauté juive aux
musulmans et aux autres confessions
chrétiennes de faire la même chose
les catholiques sont prêts les autres
vont réponse pas tarder à l'être
donc dès que tout ça sera possible et
dans pas plus que huit jours puisque
c'est l'obligation faites un conseil
d'état gouvernement ont il faudra que
ses modalités concrètes soient définies
est la décision du conseil d'état a été
salué de manière positive avant on l'a
dit un parent les catholiques est
accueillie avec plus de prudence par les
responsables juifs et musulmans ils
attendaient des précisions vous je pense
également des précisions concernant les
mesures qui vont être racontée oui et je
comprends que je comprends qu'ils aient
besoin qu'ils soient dans cette espèce
d'attentes parce que il ne faudrait pas
d'ailleurs ça a été rappelé à l'audience
vendredi après midi au conseil d'état il
n'appartient pas au gouvernement
français de fixer des conditions
matérielles de célébration des offices
que les cultes devrait respecter parce
que l'état le gouvernement s'il faisait
ça porterait atteinte à sa neutralité en
matière religieuse en la neutralité des
cas vous savez est un principe chez nous
à valeur constitutionnelle
en revanche il appartient au
gouvernement de mettre en oeuvre le
dialogue avec les grandes confessions
pour que tous les français encore une
fois qu'ils soient croyants ou qu'on
puisse avoir le droit d'accéder à ces
offices religieux à partir au plus tard
à partir du lundi 25 au 26 mai c'est
donc au fond il faut que le dialogue
serait instable entre les communautés
les gouvernements et les croyants
peuvent avoir et les cultes peuvent
avoir en france ce sentiment qu'ils sont
assez largement méprisé depuis le début
de cette crise met d'ailleurs avant le
début de cette crise et donc je
comprends l'inquiétude des communautés
juives et musulmanes sur le fait qu' ils
ne veulent pas voir l'état déboulé à
l'intérieur des mosquées pour expliquer
à quelle distance il faut s'asseoir dans
quel sens il faut se méfier terrassé par
la cepal travail de l'état le trail de
l'état c'est d'écouter les cultes comme
il écoute les entreprises comme il
écoute les commerçants comme il écoute
les restaurateurs et les autres
d'écouter les cultes pour dire voilà les
conditions dans lesquelles ça peut se
passer on négocie on se met d'accord sur
des modalités concrètes et ensuite les
choses se passeront ce n'est pas ce
compte au mieux
mais je pense qu'il y à là il ya eu de
la part du gouvernement et de l'état une
manière très offensive est contraire à
ses propres principes de considérer les
libertés fondamentales dans cette
affairé si ce que pour céder tarde à
payer un jean frédéric poisson merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes présidente du
parti chrétien démocrate